[Music]
hi everyone I'm Anthony Goldblum I'm the
CEO of Kegel and as of actually it was
at this event two years ago that we
announced that carol was joining Google
so that the Google next has a sort of a
nice sentimental
you know it's sentimental for us I'm
just a quick show of hands how many of
you have heard of Carol before well I
guess that's why you're here how many of
you have a kaggle account are nice this
is good
how many of you have either either
submitted to a competition written a
kernel or downloaded a data set okay
cool
so hopefully the percentage got a little
bit low towards the end but hopefully
this is so exciting that by the end of
it by the end of this talk you're all
dying to do all three of those things so
we run as a our own brand and our own
team within Google you can think of us
you know the you can think of us as you
know which we're a very large machine
learning community we have 2.8 members
and actually we were 840,000 when we
were when we joined Google two years ago
and so our growth is sort of a
reflection of how machine learning has
grown and evolved and so one of the
things we we've been we think a lot
about is how do we give our community
you know we're a platform neutral
community and so people who news
whatever they like but Google has a lot
you know one of the really nice things
about partnering with Google is Google
is my opinion the world's best data
analytics machine learning company and
Google cloud is you know really moving
towards being the best cloud for data
analytics and machine learning and so
one of the things that we've been
starting to experiment with a little bit
is what are the ways that we can give
the capital community exposure to Google
and Google cloud tools and so we're just
at the beginnings of this journey a lot
of our first couple of years at Google
have been focused on aligning with
Google infrastructure security and
privacy policies you know as a small
start-up you have a different stance on
on things like gdpr - you know - a
company like Google now that a lot of
that work is behind us with you yeah
we're thinking a lot about what are the
ways that you know what are the things
that Google has that would be very
exciting to our community and so Rachael
is going to give you a bit of a sense
for some of the early things that we
have done and then you know as Rachel
said there's a Dory so we're very happy
to take questions about you know what
are the what are the kinds of things
we're thinking about and what sort of
things might be coming so I'm gonna hand
it over to Rachel thank you and if you
haven't used any of the dories before it
should be in the app under this session
there's a little like Q&A button and if
you get that you can answer questions
and we'll we'll try to save a nice big
chunk of time at the end because I know
calculus is the best and you guys always
have lots of questions and I want to
make sure we have time to address those
so I think most of you know what Kaggle
is based on the the show of hands the
thing that I first and foremost think
about when I think about Kegel is the
community that's really a technical
professional community where people who
are entering the space or have been
working for a while can make friends
hangout hone their skills learn things
share resources and eventually we want
to be able to support you in doing all
of your data science work on Kangol
what's on cackle of people lots of
people I know I mentioned the community
a lot but I think calculators are the
best we've got over 2.7 million users at
this point I think we have around
300,000 people who log in every month to
you know write kernels or our download
datasets or enter competitions we also
have 15,000 public datasets so these are
data sets that we've uploaded or mostly
that users have uploaded that they want
to share so things they've collected
research datasets we'll talk a little
bit about some examples of those and we
also have a really large body of scripts
and notebooks so this is code for doing
different tasks and you can of course
work privately keep your data private
keep your code private but people really
are very generous with their work and to
share it and want people how through
buck people through how did you very
much
learning tasks so if you're trying to do
you know something kind of common let's
say sentiment analysis or object
detection probably somebody's already
written to Colonel then you can go give
a little up vote too you want to make
sure you up vote you split Colonels and
then fork and you don't have to start
from scratch you can use this pipeline
that somebody else has already built and
it's a huge time saver
I am always using other people's cry
little kernels to to get my work started
so we're probably best known as a
competitions platform that's sort of how
we got our start and we absolutely still
do that but these days Kegel is a lot
more than competitions and I want to
highlight some of the things that we've
done recently some of the changes so the
cattle products that I personally
probably use the most is kernels what
are kernels I mean they're like 18
different things in data science and
computer science so Kaggle kernels are a
hosted in browser coding environment so
we support Jupiter notebooks that's by
far the most popular
we support the Python 3 and our kernels
we do not support Python 2 and we also
have scripts so these are flat files and
we support Python R and also our
markdown so if you're any any R markdown
fans out here yeah I have a big fan of
markdown so you can write and run
markdown on cattle and then you have a
nice link that you can share with people
or I mean of course download and use
blog down or book down or slide down or
whatever else you're using in the
ecosystem and we also have once you've
created your kernels a really nice way
to share it you make it public you can
post about it on the forums if you
haven't been on the site in a while we
now have a personalized news feed so
we've sort of like algorithmically
picked some kernels that we think might
be exciting for you or competition
announcements we think you might like so
you can always see what's new and
happening and people are talking about
and there's a progression system for
kernels and datasets as well as for
competitions so uploading other people's
data sets and kernels sorry uploading
other people's forum posts and kernels
helps them progress in the competition
system and say
the community values my work that's just
a nice thing to to learn about that
others value you or your work or to to
let people know that you appreciate what
they do so here is an example kernel
that is a little bit small that I wrote
and this is an arbor kernel I like our I
also use Python and this shows you how
to read in a wav file and create a
spectrogram and if you're not familiar
spectrums are a time frequency intensity
transformation of audio files it's a way
to visualize sounds basically and this
shows you the sounds of ground parrots
which are an Australian parrot that
lives on the ground and a bio acoustics
researcher just uploaded a data set of
coals that they'd recorded from these
parrots and I was like I've got an
acoustics background I think that's kind
of interesting so I just whipped up a
little visualization to show what they
looked like and if somebody else wanted
to do spectrograms we do have a sound
bass competition going on right now you
could copy this kernel of work this
kernel to read in a different data set
remove the data set that I'd used and
just reapply this code to a new data set
so I mentioned collaborations and
discussions our forums are super duper
duper active it's a really great place
to ask technical questions to a
community of other data scientists and
of course there's there's lots of places
to do that their stack overflow their
stats exchange but particularly around
machine learning deep learning machine
learning engineering the cago community
is really great and supportive and we
also have events so some of those are in
person and some of those are digital so
an example of an in-person event is
candle days this is a picture of
everybody who went to Kaggle Days Paris
which is a little while ago we're
currently actually having a Google days
right now in conjunction with next which
I'm afraid is full so if you didn't sign
up ahead of time catch us next year and
it's been really great we've gotten
talks by Grand Master's people have run
workshops we're doing a little on-site
competition that people are working on
right now
with with manufacturing prediction
defect detection and it's been a really
fantastic way to meet people face to
face because you spend so much time
chatting with them online or maybe you
just sort of like see them going past in
the forums and you're like oh I don't
know if I could ever approach them and
it's been really great to meet people
face to face so if you are interested in
coming and hanging out with Kay glares
keep an eye out for title days and we
also have online events and we know that
we have a lot of users in different
parts of the world for whom it may not
be reasonable to get to say Paris or San
Francisco so we really want to make sure
that we're reaching everybody and we're
really being accessible and even if you
are you know in the US and you have
small children and can't travel we want
to make sure that you can still grow
professionally as the data scientist so
one of the things that we're doing next
week actually and you can still sign up
for this is career con and this is a
completely digital event to help you
land your first data science job so I'm
doing an educational event as part of
this to help people who've never made an
API make an API from scratch we're gonna
talk about open API you may know it as
swagger we're gonna build a little
flasks app we're gonna serve it we're
gonna go through the process so you can
have something to show on your portfolio
your best mates say hey sure I'm a data
scientist it's not really good at
machine learning but also I know a
little bit about what software engineers
do and I can play well with them and my
my new teammates and you should hire me
and I'm great data
I was actually originally hired to be on
the data sets team and we used to like
the Kaggle team individually go and find
interesting data sets under open
licenses and upload them to Kaggle we
don't need to do that anymore because
our community has been so so so
fantastic about sharing data research
data just people who have questions that
they would like to get in front of
machine learning researchers that
they've collected the data for and if
you have data that you would like to
share I would encourage you to put it on
Pagal assuming that we can support your
specific needs for example we cannot
support HIPAA compliance please don't
give us HIPAA data yet so here are some
example data sets that the team actually
automatically made
and these are our open datasets that we
think might be useful in your day to day
work so some things there's one in here
that San Francisco restaurant scores
like their health scores so if you're
trying to decide where to go for dinner
and you want to do a quick little data
analysis to make sure you pick the right
place that might be something you can
work on but we also have some really
fantastic user uploaded datasets so you
guys might be familiar with km NIST it
was uploaded by a couple of our users
including anarchists who's our youngest
grandmaster currently Cu and it is a
drag-and-drop replacement for a mist
which is a digit recognition data set
does anyone not familiar with feminists
yes a few okay so it's a data set for
for recognizing handwritten digits like
1 through 0 this is the same thing but
for Japanese classical texts so this
team put together this data set they
released it on Cagle and they actually
presented a paper about it at Europe's
which is what nips is called now I'm not
saying putting data sets on cago look at
you nerds papers but it's a really good
place to find interesting research data
set that's specifically tailored towards
the machine learning community which is
fantastic we also had relatively
recently some farmer who wanted to train
a drone to spritz some what's it called
not pesticide but like for plants
fertilizer no the other one herbicide
thank you herbicide on a specific weed
that he had so we've gone through his
field and he took like a bunch of
pictures of the specific weed he wanted
to target and uploaded them so that
people could could try their hand at a
really fun practical application so
there's lots to discover in datasets I
love just like going through there and
seeing what people have uploaded and
finally keidel is a great place to
challenge yourself of course we have
competitions they are as you might
imagine competitive we've got many going
on right now we've got images Lee text
we got a sound one going on right now so
whatever it is you're interested in as
long as it's supervised we'll probably
have something that might tickle your
fancy
we also have a lot of support for people
who are learning who are newer to the
data science space who maybe just aren't
compelled to compete or don't find that
particularly motivating I personally
tend to be more motivated by finding out
new things than doing like you know
gotta get that last hundreds of a digit
of accuracy and that's just my personal
learning style so here is an example
competition I know I've talked about
career Khan a lot but I'm really excited
you guys here's a competition that we're
going to be doing as part of career Khan
on robot navigation so if you're
interested in sort of agent base stuff
this might be one for you to take a
little look at and we also have a
growing number of learn courses and
these are not gonna take you from you
know completely through the map in a
very detailed way our goal with learn is
to get you started very quickly with
practical examples so these are short
they're condensed and we want you to be
able to go through them and say an
afternoon and then be able to apply what
you've learned so this is one that's
relatively new on machine learning
explain ability that diem Becker
recently released so if that's something
you're interested in sit down spend a
few hours work through some hands-on
examples and know more maybe unless
you're already researching machine
learning excitability in which case I
don't know why you take a course in it
okay so that's what's on the platform I
also want to talk about some of our
Google integrations that we've already
added and something that I was doing is
I was putting together this talk was
really sitting down and thinking how
will these be helpful what specific
people can I see really benefiting from
these integrations because we want to
make sure that we're doing things that
people can take with them and enjoy and
improve their work with so three things
that we've added relatively recently one
is an integration with data studio who
used is who has used data studio okay a
fair number of people
we've also added an integration with
bigquery and also Google sheets which
I'm actually very excited about and I'll
talk about why I know people like to
dunk on like spreadsheet software but
it's a great tool you guys
these are great all right data studio so
we have a little gift here that's
apparently starting in the middle for
some reason interesting
so you can click on any title data set
and launched with just a couple button
clicks once you've connected your data
studio account a de Dios to do dashboard
based on that data if you're not
familiar with that data studio is a way
to visually analyze data it's really
nice for creating dashboards in
particular and one use case where I
think this is gonna be a huge time-saver
is for people who are working in
educational settings so particularly if
you want your students to really analyze
the specific data set just as an example
the Arizona Secretary of State releases
their data sets of election data as they
finish cleaning them on kaggle so if
you're a government professor and you
want your students to spend some time
looking at election data I don't know
how many of you have done mapping or
like GIS stuff in Python or are ya is it
like fast and easy and something you can
do in 10 minutes usually maybe some of
you can but me I'm always like ah got a
pic of projection oh no there's no FIPS
code I got to go get the FIPS code from
somewhere or oh I've got to hook up a
mapping API because I don't have like
open Street on whatever I'm doing so I
think this could be a really fast way
particularly for mapping especially if
you want your students to be focusing on
the information in the map and not the
going through of the mapping also I
mentioned dashboards
I love Jupiter there are some things
that Jupiter is really great for
dashboarding there are some things where
it's like a little bit less good so
something that actually there's a
front-end people in here who would like
to contribute to Jupiter there's an HTML
widgets bug that I don't think the core
team is gonna get to cuz they're
focusing on Jupiter lab it's been around
for a while and every so often different
plots will render as one pixel by one
pixel has any wandering into this anyway
when you're working with interactive
plodding libraries that can happen and
if you run into that again it's just in
the Jupiter core and there's not
I personally can do about it cuz I'm not
a French person if you are consider
making open source contributions on this
particular vlog that bothers me but
using data lab instead is a nice way to
work around that and it's also nice for
your your teammates who are maybe not so
comfortable working with code I know
that a lot of us work in teams with
people with variety of backgrounds and
goals so this is a nice way to reach out
and and work with them
bigquery who uses bigquery ok I've heard
of people uses like any relational
database or sequel in general yeah ok
pretty much everybody so right now you
can access public bigquery datasets
through chi bowl kernels and we've got
some very small code examples I don't
know why I thought these screens would
be bigger I think I thought the room
would be smaller so everyone would be a
little bit closer so you can create a
bigquery client and run queries Wow I
should have had a second coffee and run
queries from directly in kaggle
notebooks and then take that data and
work with it locally save it out as
another data set so if you save any
files from a Jupiter notebook when you
commit that notebook it'll run it top to
bottom and your files would be saved in
the output and you can create a new data
set from those so if you're running a
big query or maybe you have a teammate
who's not as familiar with sequel but
they want to use some of the the
bigquery public data you can run the
queries create a data set from them and
then point them to the data set which is
really nice and if you are perhaps the
person who is like I don't like sequel
or maybe it's been a minute since you
used it we also have a sequel course
again very directed we're not gonna get
into like you know the parse trees of
sequel and have sections action not
doing any of that it's just basics of
query writing and specifically talking a
little bit about bigquery and how to use
it on Kaggle so if you're a little
trepidatious about getting started we
can help you out with that and walk you
through it
just for those of you who didn't know we
have a kegel developer survey that we
reach out to the machine learning
community in large and sort of get
information back
and sequel is consistently the third
most popular language after Python and
are so if you are not a sequel user and
you're working the machine learning face
that's good to know finally Google
sheets I really like spreadsheet
software I think I mentioned it before I
think it's a really nice tool set that
makes a lot of things very except very
accessible to people because you don't
have the cognitive over of trying to
remember what data structures look like
because it's there visually so I know
people don't gone on on spreadsheet
software but I'm a big fan so to open
datasets in a Google sheet you can do
that I don't know if you guys can see
it's under that little sort of hamburger
sweet menu in the upper right hand
corner and you can open it as a Google
sheet it takes just a second and then
it'll pop open so two places where I
think that this might be a sort of a
surprising news is first for project
management so if you've got I mentioned
that you can create a dataset from the
output files you generate in any kernel
so let's say you're working with some
competition teammates you're sort of
deciding what your hyper parameter
search space is going to be you generate
a file with sort of all the parameters
you create a dataset from it launch it
as a sheet and then you can use that as
your sort of base of operations so you
know color code who's doing what you can
ping people so you can be like this
action item is for you and they'll get
an email which is really nice so it can
be a nice project management tool
because I know that that's something
that a lot of people struggle with and I
see a lot of discussion about on the
forum so if you don't already have one
and you're working with other people
sheets might be a nice integration and a
really hacky one I'm sorry guys this is
extremely hockey but I think would be
useful so one of the ways that people do
text data augmentation so you have a
small data set how can you create new
data items for images you can you know
flip it and rotate it what does it mean
to flip the sentence it sort of stops
becoming language one way that people do
this is they'll translate from English
into an unrelated language like Japanese
or Russian and then back into English
because you'll get sort of like slightly
different sentences that are kind of
semantically equivalent
and I don't know if you guys know this
but there's actually a Google Translate
option in sheets now so one way to do
this would be to create a data set of
the text data you want opening sheets
translate it using sheets and then
create a new data set from your
translated sentences for your data
augmentation I did warn you always hacky
but potentially very useful if you need
to do text augmentation so those are
some of the integrations that we have
worked on so far more to come TM veil of
secrecy but there's lots of exciting
things that we're working on that I
think you'll really like and find useful
and we really want to make kaggle a
great place to do data science so I
encourage you during the Q&A I haven't
checked the dory hopefully everyone's
asking questions so let us know your
feedback if there are specific things
you want to see we would love to hear
that we really want to make cago a great
tool I do almost all of my data science
working Hegel and personally would like
it to be better for selfish reasons I
think it's already very good but I'd
love to hear what else we can do to help
you guys alright and also there is
feedback in the app so I'm gonna wrap it
up and we can take questions
[Applause]
[Music]